[Musica]
ogni giorno in italia 42 persone
diventano celiache domani una di quelle
potresti essere tu
[Musica]
domani questi 42 nuovi celiaci saranno
sicuramente tutti disorientati
probabilmente la metà di loro non saprà
neanche che cosa comporta un quarto di
loro piangerà dalla mattina alla sera
il quarto rimanente andrà avanti con la
sua vita come se nulla fosse successo
dal giorno dopo inizieranno a
metabolizzare di avere quella che è a
tutti gli effetti una malattia cronica e
capiranno di dover cambiare e
stravolgere la loro vita in un giorno da
celiaca posso dirvi che sert al giorno
d'oggi ci sono un sacco di ristorante
attrezzati di cibo finalmente buono che
negli anni ottanta neanche potevamo
immaginarci queste possibilità ma posso
anche dirvi che non si riesce a uscire a
prendere un aperitivo una pizza con gli
amici quando non si sente a proprio agio
in casa con la propria cucina
anche a me è successo così mi sentivo
come un malato perenne che non poteva
uscire di casa finché non gli fosse
passata la febbre ma questa febbre non
passava ho trascorso tre anni della mia
vita chiusa in casa a rifiutare inviti a
farmi rovinare la giornata da un pasto
andato storto cercando di uscire da
questo guscio
ho provato ad accettare un invito a un
compleanno in pizzeria il festeggiato
mi aveva assicurato che era tutto a
posto che potevo stare tranquilla allora
ho ordinato la mia pizza senza glutine
quando sono arrivate le pizze
sì la mia era diversa da quella degli
altri ma era fatta con farina di grano
integrale che contiene glutine
chiaramente quella sera non ho mangiato
e ho trascorso le successive due ore a
guardare i miei amici che non si
accorgeva neanche della fortuna che
avevano
da questa esperienza ho capito che io
dovevo essere la prima mettermi in gioco
a informarmi per poter stare bene ma
anche questo a volte non basta per la
prima volta un ragazzo mi chiese di
uscire felicissima mi ha dato la scelta
del luogo
allora subito ho pensato a quella
gelateria in cui ero sicura di poter
mangiare arrivati lì
il ragazzo ha preso il suo cono col
gelato normale io ho preso la mia
coppetta congelato senza glutine
finito il gelato ragazzo mia smollato lì
su due piedi dicendo che non voleva più
uscire con una ragazza malata
adesso ci rido sopra
ma per una bambina di 13 anni è stato
davvero un colpo basso negli ultimi
tempi ho deciso che ero stanca stanca di
sentirmi malata di sentirmi sfortunata
di colpevolizzare i miei genitori per
qualcosa che non hanno scelto ma come si
può fare per prima di tutto basta non
sei la vittima non è la morte di nessuno
sa è quello di prima io sono quella di
prima non devo totalizzare mi con la
malattia o identificarmi in essa e poi
gli altri gli altri continuamente
compiano dei passi per te per venirti
incontro per farti stare bene
proprio in queste ultime settimane una
persona che mi è molto cara che
frequenta medicina bologna ha avuto la
possibilità di accedere agli archivi
delle ultime scoperte in ambito
scientifico e medico poteva cercare di
tutto la prima cosa la prima primissima
cosa che ha cercato è stata una cura per
la celiachia delle altre persone hanno
imparato a cucinare per me hanno
mangiato senza glutine solo per poter
condividere un pasto per me con me
queste sono le cose che io mi voglio
portare dietro queste sono le cose che
voglio valorizzare che devo valorizzare
la celiachia può essere una ricchezza lo
deve diventare altrimenti sarei malato
per sempre e non solo di celiachia ma
anche di soddisfazione vittimismo ma può
una malattia cronica essere una
ricchezza
prima di tutto ti forma al carattere
dopo tutte le esperienze che hai passato
non ti farai più mettere i piedi in
testa da nessuno facendo della malattia
altro punto forte
nessuno la può usare contro di te in più
preparati a essere al centro
dell'attenzione a dover spiegare
millemila volte cosa può e cosa non puoi
mangiare ti assicuro che tutti ti
ricorderanno infine contribuirà alla
diffusione dell'informazione generale
quindi aprirà gli occhi a più
disinformati e grazie a te si sentiranno
fortunati ad ogni pasto
così facendo la celiachia può diventare
un modo di parlare di aprirsi agli altri
di dialogare
io ho fatto della celiachia non una
malattia ma uno stile di vita
io non sono affetta da morbo celiaco
sono una persona celiaca quasi come se
fosse una cittadinanza acquisita nessuno
di noi può cambiare patrimonio il
proprio patrimonio genetico
io rimarrò celiaca per sempre ma si può
decidere come viverlo questo per sempre
[Musica]
e magari tra di voi non c'è nessun
celiaco allo stesso modo ci può essere
diabetico intolleranti ai latticini una
persona allergica o semplicemente una
persona che vive male su avere il naso
storto
il discorso non cambia non dovete
lasciare che la vostra condizione vi
definisca sta a voi decidere se essere
malati o meno sta a voi decidere se
focalizzarvi sul vostro limite e vivere
da vittime o prendere in mano le cose e
cambiarle e vivere da protagonisti
io ho scelto di essere protagonista e tu
grassi
[Applauso]
[Musica]